Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man, we're wings, is such a wondrous thing.
Be high, doves of rum, see, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for...
Just that you continue your fascinating story after class.
Now, now, silence, silence, silence, my young friend.
Isolation, Andromeda, which we can reach in a few days, is considered by terrestrials to be at a distance of two million light years from their planet.
Hence, they observe it as it was at the time of the...
What is it?
Come in.
Expecting you, gentlemen.
Commander?
Here is our report.
I'm sure that some parts of it will appear very strange.
Strange? What do you mean?
Let's look at two things, Colonel.
Consider the facts.
Their ship has a sudden breakdown, just as it's entering the world of Pegasus.
Yes, well...
Don't you think that's a little strange?
It's the first time that ever happened.
And the second thing, the planet Lago, according to our information, has no life on it.
Now the captain will tell you what he thinks.
It's a mystery, I'll admit that.
This sort of breakdown is pretty rare.
You might think it wasn't accidental.
Colonel, I think you'd better hear the whole story from the start.
Just routine. Not too boring?
Pegasus system now in visual field.
In 15 seconds, we cross space border.
I heard that General Grouchley doesn't like anyone to come here.
Don't worry, he'll get used to it.
Stabilization circuits attempting to make compensating corrections to your station
Press it better not go on much longer
Otherwise facing source of fault made it repaired negative extensive suggest manual repair immediately hurry go and repair it
Go ahead go down and take a look in on present trajectory in six minutes
We are in gravitational field planet X 47 logo hurry up somebody go down and help him
We had a chief mechanic on board who was qualified
He carried out emergency repairs and was able to restore all circuits.
A few seconds more and we'd have disintegrated.
Done an investigation, I suppose.
It was difficult because many of the cables melted during this incident.
We can't tell what happened, sabotage or accidental.
Personally, I'm not able to say.
I see.
And you were approaching Lago.
Yes, sir.
We took some pictures.
The color is mainly green and I believe there's some kind of atmosphere that can support a life system.
There's an ocean and some large lakes to support vegetation.
The InfraVision never showed up any trace of a heat source, no laser radar echo, no radio signals at all.
Yes, you're right. It doesn't make sense. It's a contradiction.
Thank you, Captain.
What do you think?
Same as you. I don't understand.
Let's go and see Perrette. Be her decision what to do.
Atmosphere. Therefore, it can support life.
Dense jungle.
And obviously supporting life.
This proves the report sent in by General Grashley is completely wrong.
He appears to be deceiving us deliberately.
What do you want?
That's easy. I'll tell you. He wants a fight. What else would he want?
Well, we'd better put things straight. I propose we see what it's all about.
Good idea.
More interruptions.
Yes, who is it?
Hello?
Look here, this is not the right time. I'm very busy right now.
You said that we could see your android, maestro.
Well, uh, hmm.
Yes, what you say you will do, you must do, metro.
Hear the way that he pronounced your name?
He called you metro.
Hmm.
He must have a wire that's come undone.
and I'll just have a little peek inside and see what it is.
No, Maestro, let him stay that way.
Metro sounds just fine.
The android's name is Metro.
Metro, well, that's a funny name.
How do you like it?
I think it's splendid.
Metro, what can you do?
I can do everything, Master Ken,
but naturally I am a lot less muddle-headed.
What's that, I'm muddle-headed?
Let's not get off on that subject again.
You know very well it will lead nowhere.
He's a great robot.
You suppose you could make me one that's exactly like him, exactly like him?
What?
In that case, you will allow me to give you a word of advice.
Select a model without a beard. A long beard is ridiculous.
Maestro Pierrot, the commander, report to the colonel's office immediately.
You're going to be assigned to a mission. Be careful.
There's something that tells me these unknown worlds are dangerous.
Anyway, we're going to be together.
The only word for it is strange.
Very well. Here is a detailed explanation of your exact mission.
Listen carefully, you youngsters. Objective, Planet Lago.
Reconnaissance mission following standard procedure.
First, gather all data available concerning inhabitants of any sort.
Second, discover if there's a civilization and make contact.
And third, if its level is sufficiently advanced,
report on the possibility of incorporating it into our confederation.
Craft will be a light cruiser, fully armed, crew of six.
Father, will I command it to our ship?
Light cruiser?
Know what that means?
No, Gero, not this time.
But Dad, why not?
You said I could.
Lieutenant, here, I am the one in charge.
Now then, there is some mystery hidden in this business, a danger.
Yes, Colonel?
That's why I am putting the commander in charge.
What is it?
What about that we land?
Yes.
Okay.
The commander suggests once you are on the planet, there is no reason why you can't take command, Lieutenant.
Yes, sir.
At that point, your superior will be no more than an observer and counselor.
As for you, Maestro, you're a bit too slow.
Where is your android?
I believe it was supposed to be ready for trials.
Well, all work and no play, as they say.
Well, look here, young man.
I wouldn't laugh.
You can be replaced one day by one of my little robots.
Take him along.
You will see what I mean.
You'll assist me in the descent.
You see a sort of plateau there?
It will serve as a good observation center.
I'll remain in command of the ship,
but from now on, you will be in charge of the expedition.
Attention, crew.
This is Lieutenant Pierrot calling the crew.
As soon as we land, the second lieutenant and myself
will set off on our reconnaissance mission the others stay on board awaiting orders from our
commander two will sleep the third keeps watch surveying the terrain the last will stay in radio
contact if we should request assistance or if no contact for three hours a search and rescue unit
will be sent out by the commander they're landing chief i could see that for myself idiot what are
your honors chief weapons in firing positions wait for my orders ready to fire time see that
What's that big hunk of machinery there?
Let 'em come closer, they're fug to watch.
Bugs, aren't they?
We can eat them.
The ugliest things I ever saw, yeah.
Worse than that, they're disgusting.
They walk on two little tails, huh?
There are only two of them.
Can't be too dangerous.
Hey, hey, hey, wait, wait, wait, what about me?
Hey, hey, hey!
Leave that one.
What is it, walking artichoke or a weapon?
Better warn the council.
So, you'd just leave me in a closet, would you?
That's very intelligent. I take all the trouble of coming here, and you just let me rust away on the landing craft, really.
He fusses as much as Maestro. You think his complaining is built in?
Okay, no distractions. It's unknown territory.
You stay ten paces back and weapon in hand, ready to go into action no matter what.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, okay, let's go. We'll start off that way.
Don't know why, but it's hard to breathe.
The atmosphere is rich in carbon dioxide. It accelerates the pulse.
By the way, maybe you'll tell me whether the planet we're exploring is inhabited.
An impossibly stupid question.
How am I supposed to reply when I have insufficient information?
What am I clairvoyant or...
They're so ugly.
Or contain some very strange species.
Species? That's easy to say.
But what are they? I think they're insects.
Really stupid nonsense, my brothers.
These are intelligent creatures.
Why do you say that, Father Ratloss?
Do they look like us?
No, they're horrible.
You can say that again.
They're horrible.
It follows that there is a world where there are species different from us.
Agreed?
Do you agree?
To build a machine like that, they must have some intelligence.
So let us make contact with these repulsive foreigners.
Perhaps it's in our interest.
In any case, there is always time to take action.
Yes, at least we can meet them.
He's right.
For the crocodiles?
Let them come.
After all, what can they do to us?
Yes, why not?
Let them come.
They might taste delicious.
Come, come, Theodol. Keep calm.
Still on the path.
Just one second.
Vegetation exactly conforms to that of the Triassic period, 200 million years ago.
You're a regular genius.
Excited, quite right.
We bid you all welcome.
Yes, well, to our land.
The stanzas.
We have come here in peace.
Ridiculous gurgling sound it makes.
Wait, I'll find the old wise one.
He knows everything.
Kind of nice in a way, these pet lizards.
Too bad we can't understand them.
Descendants from the Saltoparkas, originating as crocodiles, dinosaurs, and winged reptiles.
Circulatory system, top side.
They do not seem hostile, appears they would like to make contact.
End of report.
I'll tell you, if they're all like this one, I imagine they're pretty powerful.
Trigger finger ready and eyes open.
You too, don't go to sleep, okay?
I don't sleep. What should I do?
I want to tell you that we are here as ambassadors of peace from another world.
I understand you. We wish to welcome you here in peace.
Huh?
Oh, that's right, you aren't receiving me. Wait, try.
Listen, now you can understand. Welcome to here.
Well, I never saw that talking lizard.
Why not?
Now let us talk.
If you will follow us to our city, we will be very honored.
Friends look worried.
Are they scared?
No, they don't talk much.
Guess they're a bit shy.
Oh, yes, I understand.
Each to his own ways.
That's how it is.
You need to receive your language to understand it.
How do you explain the fact that a people who can construct a flying machine with all its marvels cannot communicate through telepathy?
Oh, it's a very special gift you have.
Ah, yes.
Just as I thought.
Mm-hmm. They're more like Megalobatharachis rather than the planobracatavitkia.
A clever fellow.
Yes, he is. He's the smartest among us.
I wouldn't say we're much like him.
No. Back home, we call him an intelligent robot.
That little skinny one tastes good.
I've got my eye on that one over there. Lots of meat on that one.
A little more respect for our honored guests.
Come and see our sports field.
We're playing the tail-bashing championship.
Take a look.
Can I ask you, I don't understand something.
How is it your females lay something like 50 or more eggs, but each family has only two children?
How do you manage to arrange that?
Three for especially meritorious families.
Enough, isn't it?
Yes, but, well, where are the others?
Why, we eat them.
Quite delicious.
A truly tasty dish.
If you are still here when they're in season, you will taste some.
Oh, yes, but, well, they're your own children.
Oh, no, not quite.
Not yet.
And besides, what would you have us do?
Ensure that. You know the formula. There are 4 billion of us on the planet.
If you multiply that figure by 50 every year, what is the total that you end up?
In one year, exactly 200 billion. Exactly in two years, 10,000 billion.
In three years, 50,000 billion, etc.
It's easy. The first thing to do is clear the field so you can tail the ball into your opponent's goal.
Let's go, lizards! Let's go, lizards! Let's go!
Very nice, kind, practically civilized.
Could they join our confederation? Not like us at all.
Let's go, lizards.
They have no masters or slaves or cast or races, in my opinion. Positive.
On the other hand, they hold no beliefs, have no language or art.
As for their philosophy, it's quite elementary.
Yeah, well, all the same, I mean, soccer, we can't beat them, but it's true.
They don't always distinguish between the opponent and the ball.
Didn't happen to run into General Grouchley.
No, no sign of him. We talked about a great many things.
The one thing that bothers me is that they still reproduce by laying eggs.
And the fact that they eat their surplus, it's well like cannibalism.
Look, Commander, why not come with us tomorrow? I understand that their Grand Council will be in session. You can judge.
I told you, Lieutenant, you're in charge. I follow your orders.
I've been given to understand that your species has never known war.
Ah, war. Well, let me think. The old legends speak of our having shared the planet with some other creatures.
They were a distant relative.
Crocodile lizards. Cousins, I suppose.
They were stupid creatures.
Aggressive, dangerous.
They used to come and share our eggs.
They were enough for everyone.
But then, one day, they started to attack our adults,
our women, and children.
Naturally, we had to put a stop to that.
And that meant war.
War.
We revised weapons against them,
and one by one, all of them were exterminated.
exterminated i get the impression that shocks you would have been a mistake to show any leniency
extermination was the best way to keep them from continuing the war because now we have peace as
we want it and other men like us have you ever seen anyone like us or are we the first ones you
are the first but we knew you would come one day three times now we have seen machines like yours
it's the general huh the cassiopeians this new one's even more appetizing than the others right
You are, but the elders aren't going to like it.
Old fogies, all they do is grumble.
Meanwhile, they know that us kids have to have a little fun every once in a while.
Well, naturally, there's a social code governing your way of life.
Any laws?
I don't know what good laws would be.
We don't need them here at all.
We don't bother with them.
Everybody does what he wants according to his instinct,
so long as he doesn't get in anyone else's way.
Of course, the young ones.
They can be impetuous sometimes, but you know what it's like to be young.
Watch out! Watch out!
Let's go!
Watch out! They're right behind us! Turn and fire!
Hey there!
Who's not with us? What's he doing?
Wait for me!
Well, Metro, late as usual.
Doing the best I can, and you're not funny.
I'd like to see you with arrows bulking up all your circuits.
I just might blow a fuse or something.
Congratulations.
Oh, you did a good job.
They can get rough, those friends of ours, when they want to, right?
How were they to know that our paralyzers would only knock them out for an hour?
By now, they should be coming, too.
We have a little punch-up at the end, anyway.
Too impulsive, my son.
It would appear that I alone was wounded.
Hardly seems right.
What a character.
Don't worry, Maestro will put you together again.
You'll be as good as new.